como una pista voy a calcular el
determinante de esta otra matriz aquí
tenemos la matriz aquí tenemos el
determinante de esa matriz y bueno voy a
usar exactamente el mismo método para
esta matriz en particular que tú estás
tratando de encontrar para cualquier
matriz de tres por tres ok entonces lo
primero que hay que recordar es que
vamos a sacar el determinante utilizando
esta fila y que esta entrada va con un
signo más la siguiente entrada va con un
signo menos y después la siguiente
entrada va otra vez con un signo más ok
bien entonces vamos a tomar la primera
entrada de nuestra fila y la vamos a
multiplicar por la menor de esa matriz
con respecto a esta entrada
ok y qué es lo que eso signifique pues
eso significa que vamos a tomar esta
matriz y le vamos a quitar la columna a
la que pertenece nuestra entrada y
también le vamos a quitar la fila a la
que pertenece y eso lo que nos deja es
una
su matriz está su matriz 5300 y la menor
lo que es es el determinante de esa su
matriz gay entonces lo primero que
tenemos es un signo más más la primera
entrada de nuestra fila que es el cuatro
por la menor de esa entrada que es el
determinante de 5300 530
y ahora vamos a ir con la siguiente
entrada que es esta entrada el -1 pero a
esta entrada le corresponde el signo
menos por lo cual aquí tenemos que
restarle nuestra siguiente entrada que
en este caso es uno menos uno y ya eso
lo tenemos que multiplicar por la menor
de esta entrada que para sacarla pues
tenemos que quitar esta columna y esta
fila y entonces lo que nos queda es el
determinante de la matriz que está
conformada por 43 menos 2 y 0 o sea aquí
tenemos que multiplicar por el
determinante de 43 menos 2
y ahora vamos con la última entrada esta
entrada tiene signo más o sea que vamos
a sumar nuestra entrada que es un 1 x
el determinante de lo que nos queda de
quitar esta columna y esta fila o sea el
determinante de esta matriz así es que
tenemos que multiplicar por el
determinante de 45 menos 2 y 0
bien ahora lo último que nos falta es
simplemente hacer estas cuentas de
cuánto valen estos determinantes y sumar
toda esta cosa ok entonces tenemos
cuatro por este determinante que es 5
por 0 5 por 0 que es cero menos tres por
cero
es por cero y esto lo que nos queda es
500 menos tres por cero eso también es
cero o sea que nos queda
4 x 0 y eso también es igual a cero de
este lado tenemos menos menos uno menos
pero menos da más o sea que tenemos que
sumar y nos queda simplemente este
determinante ok y ese determinante es 4
x 0 - 3 x menos 2 ok 4 x 0 que es 0 - 3
x menos 2
ok y de eso tenemos 4 x 0 qué es
y eso tenemos que restarle tres x menos
203 por menos 2 es menos 6 claro que si
lo tenemos que restar entonces menos
menos 6 nos queda nada más 6 o sea que
esto es más
y ya lo podemos escribir por aquí más
y por acá uno por cualquier cosa nos
queda esa cosa o sea que simplemente
tenemos que sacar este determinante que
es 4 x 0 menos 5 por menos dos ok cuatro
por cero menos cinco por menos 2
gay 4 x 0 es cero
menos 5 por menos 2 eso es 10 10
entonces aquí nos queda más 10 así es
que el determinante de a es 0 + 6 + 10 o
sea 16 1 simplemente tiene que recordar
que tiene que irse a lo largo de una
fila que la primera entrada es más la
siguiente entrada es menos y luego la
siguiente entrada es otra vez más y
recuerdas que tienes que multiplicar la
entrada por el determinante de la más su
matriz que nos queda de eliminar la
columna y la fila entonces ya
simplemente tiene que ser puras cuentas
y listo
nada más que no se te olvide lo de los
signos y que no te equivoques a la hora
de hacer cuentas y ya estás listo